[Musique]
je vous l'avouer zelda est une saga qui
me passionne
énormément tous les jours je bouquine
heroes d'historia fait des recherches
sur l'univers car bon sens je laime
alors oui la timeline zelda est un réel
débat nous en avons l'exemple encore
aujourd'hui avec breath of the wild
nintendo voulait créer des zelda
indépendants à chaque nouvelle histoire
et la timeline est un peu un bonus créés
pour satisfaire les fans toujours en
demande de plus de l'or on pourra dire
ce qu'on veut mais j'aime énormément
cette timeline le fait que nintendo
n'ait jamais prévu de lier tous les
joueurs dans l'histoire mystérieuse
comme une vraie légende
ah bah dis donc ça tombe bien et
d'ailleurs les créateurs jouent
là-dessus à l'interprétation propre du
joueur et c'est justement là dessus que
nous allons théorisé cette vidéo est
important pour moi car j'aime vraiment
zelda et je vous ai imaginé trois
théories totalement personnelle sur le
lors de la licence rester jusqu'à la fin
car j'ai une ou deux annonces à vous
faire ah oui mon grand ami aerosave
participe également à la vidéo étant lui
même aussi fan de la saga zelda je me
devais de l'invité et puis il me semble
qu'ils préparent également des théories
sur ce merveilleux univers
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
pour commencer cette vidéo théorique sur
le lors de la saga zelda j'aimerais vous
parler de l'ocarina du temps
effectivement l'ocarina est un artefact
très important de la famille des rues
les fait son apparition dans ocarina of
time il est donné par zelda link lors de
son enfance pour qui son lieu sûr et
surtout qu'à elle servira à link le
héros du temps puisque gallon d'or feu
souhaitait s'en emparer pour justement
accéder aux terres d'or soit le sens
royaume où repose la triforce
alors oui je sais ce que vous allez me
dire on sait comment a été construit
l'ocarina c'est théorisé dans hyrule
historia eh bien cela ne va pas
m'empêcher d'en parler tout de même pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas la théorie
souvenez-vous de zelda skyward sword et
plus exactement de la région de l'anel à
travers cette région devenue très
désertique vous pourrez jouer à revenir
dans le temps grâce à ce qu'on appelle
des chronolithes des sortes de gros
cristaux que si link frappe permettent
d'alterner entre présent et passé
et bien justement l'ocarina du temps
serait forgé à partir de ces cristaux
nous le remarquons de par leur couleur
bleue et le fait de pouvoir retourner
dans le temps grâce à l'ocarina mais
c'est tout ce que supposent heroes
historia moi j'ai envie d'aller plus
loin qui a créé l'ocarina et pourquoi at
il été créé nous savons que l'ocarina
possède des pouvoirs magiques
il permet à son utilisateur soit link de
se téléporter grâce à des champs de
manipuler le temps et surtout d'ouvrir
la porte du sein royaume et bien
personnellement je supposerait que le
karine a été fabriquée par rue à l'aide
du peuple sheika pour rappel la triforce
suite à l'histoire de skyward sword a
suscité l'intérêt de beaucoup de
personnes allant jusqu'à créer des
guerres pour conquérir le pouvoir divin
rares auront pris donc les devants et
fonda le saint royaume pour justement
protéger ce pouvoir dit vrai que
personne ne puisse s'emparer de la
triforce dans les terres d'or le temple
du temps fut donc fondées et serait sur
l'emplacement du temple du saut là où il
pas reposé surveiller le piédestal
gardons prisonniers l'avatar du néant
bref aux rues et le sage de la lumière
et est un pilier fondateur pour hyrule
ce dernier savait forcément pour la
malédiction lancée par l'avatar du néant
comme quoi son retour ne serait qu'une
question de temps et donc un nouvel élu
existerait pour le contrer ce serait
pourquoi il crée à l'ocarina permettant
à l'élu de pouvoir accéder au sein
royaume et excalibur l'épée de légende
en temps voulu et nous avons le cas avec
ocarina of time ganondorf seigneur du
mal un roi des voleurs et la première
réincarnation de l'avatar du néant
depuis skyward sword et c'est pourquoi
l'ocarina devient donc important à ce
moment précis si on s'inspire dire
l'historia et de tout ce que je viens de
dire l'ocarina existerait depuis la fin
de skyward sword fabriqués par rue et le
peuple cheikh a mais d'ailleurs pourquoi
d'échec
je vous rappelle que le peuple de
l'ombre soit l'échec à est un peuple au
service de la ds il y as possédant une
technologie très développés ainsi que
des pouvoirs magiques
il suffit juste de voir le monocle de
vérité les créatures divines la tablette
sheika les gardiens bref j'en passe et
des meilleurs
le peuple sheika et on va dire les
ingénieurs d'hyrule il est quasiment
obvious qu'ils aient construit l'ocarina
en compagnie de rom preuve avec les
pouvoirs de l'ocarina ce dernier ne
permet pas simplement de voyager dans le
temps et de changer le jour et la nuit
faire tomber la pluie se téléporter des
pouvoirs qui ont déjà été possible de
voir grâce à la technologie chèque à
l'ocarina ferait donc partie de la
famille depuis des générations et des
générations pour que le jour où le héros
du temps apparaîtra ce dernier
puis sauver hyrule
[Musique]
quelle manière free si l'on en croit ce
qu'on raconte
il est né de notre peuple 6
voilà pourquoi nous allons l'affronter
de toutes nos forces
toi et moi
[Musique]
il faut pour l'honneur de la tribu
guerre ou d'eau attend seulement que je
le tiens
[Musique]
sachez que je suis très fier de vous
présenter cette seconde théorie 100%
personnel et imaginé par moi même allez
c'est parti
commençons par installer le contexte
dans ocarina of time l'opus zelda
fondateur de quasiment toutes à timeline
nous avons la présence du peuple des
guérido un peuple 100% composée de
femmes guerrières cependant une fois
tous les cent ans
à mal guérie données et devint
automatiquement roi de ce peuple
et c'est justement ce qui s'est passé
avec galan dorff il est un des rares mal
guérie doit naître tous les sens en
définit donc pas reprendre le pouvoir
automatiquement
mais comme vous le savez ganondorf est
le seigneur du malin est la
réincarnation de l'avatar du néant
ce dernier réussit à s'introduire dans
les terres d'or est donc le ca royaume
grâce à link et pris possession de la
triforce de la force
n'ayant pas un coeur assez pur pour
pouvoir s'emparer des trois morceaux
ganondorf a donc réduit et rule dans le
chaos et gouverna pendant sept longues
années
ganondorf est le mal incarné et est de
la race des kerdo retenez bien ceci
suite à ces longues années
link qui était auparavant trop jeune par
20 défaire le seigneur du malin et l'ont
fermée grâce à l'aide des sept sages
link est donc renvoyée dans le passé
grâce à zelda et à l'ocarina of time
pour revivre son enfance est alerte et
zelda est le roi du rhume des intentions
de ganondorf à l'égard du royaume
nous arrivons donc maintenant à majora's
mask mais inintéressant dans la théorie
puisque l'histoire se passe en termine à
une dimension parallèle mais en
continuant dans la taille de l'enfant
nous arrivons à twilight princess le
zelda clé le temps a passé et le royaume
d'hyrule a continué de perpétuer
normalement et n'a donc jamais sombrer
dans le chaos
ganondorf fut arrêté à temps ce qu'il
faut absolument noter est que dans
twilight princess
legear u2 ont disparu ils sont 100 %
absent du jeu mais d'ailleurs pourquoi
ça et bien c'est très simple
tout d'abord il faut savoir que le
peuple liens s'étaient tendues suite aux
évènements d'ocarina of time et ce
jusqu'au désert de guerre ou d'eau ces
derniers ont bâti à l'emplacement du
temple de l'esprit la tour du jugement
un endroit où reposent les sept sages
sage qui ne sont pas les mêmes que ceux
d'ocarina of time
je le précise
puisque link n'a pas eu besoin de
réveiller ce d'ocarina of time pour
arrêter ganondorf nous sommes donc en
compagnie de sage il y un et cela va
approuver encore plus la théorie vous
allez comprendre
la tour du jugement ne sert pas
seulement d'endroits où reposent les
sages au contraire ces derniers sont ici
pour juger les ennemis d'hier hull et
exécuté ces derniers ou les bannières
dans le royaume du crépuscule
l'exemple le plus pertinent et
l'exécution de ganondorf qui a très mal
tourné
car grâce au pouvoir de la triforce de
la force ce dernier a pu défaire le sage
de l'eau et fut donc bannis in extremis
dans le royaume du crépuscule maintenant
rappelez-vous d'ocarina of time et plus
particulièrement du temple de l'ombre
cet endroit effrayant abrite la
sanglante histoire des rues pleines de
cupidité et de haine la famille royale
des rues laissant peu plus n'ont pas
toujours été tout rose la preuve en est
ce temple abrite la souffrance la
torture et les exécutions met en avant
l'exemple avec l'histoire du tristement
célèbre bongo bongo le chaikin créateur
du monocle de vérité qu'il fut torturé
et détruit revenue finalement donc le
monstre de l'ombre et bien dans twilight
princess c'est exactement pareil
legear udo aurait été persécutés et
chassé par les îliens qui se sont
appropriés leur territoire et qui ont
bâti sur ce dernier la tour du jugement
en droit de leur mort et où bannissement
dans le royaume des ombres
c'est très simple à comprendre pourquoi
ganondorf la réincarnation du mal est un
gay rude au peuple qui a d'ailleurs été
les ennemis du royaume lors de la guerre
d'unification et qui est de plus trahi
la trêve de paix et l'allégeance envers
le roi d'hyrule
afin d'éviter un potentiel retour et
accessoirement se venger ce peuple
aurait été détruit par les îliens pour
éviter une catastrophe
la tour du jugement est composée de
centaines de sacs d'os stahl fausses ou
autres morts-vivants
cet endroit est le nouveau temple de
l'ombre métaphoriquement parlant mais
certains guérido aurait réussi à
échapper à ce massacre et serait revenu
dans force wars adventures néanmoins
anecdote marrante nous sommes dans
breath of the wine en compagnie d'un
homme gay rude aux travestis qui nous
transmettra un accoutrement permettant
d'intégrer la cité guérido alors oui
apparemment ce serait vraiment une femme
guérido mais je n'y crois pas du tout
l'homme guérido qui naît tous les cent
ans est censée devenir roi du peuple
mais ce dernier fut banni comme quoi
même dans breath of the wild les
craintes d'un nouveau ganondorf existe
toujours
je vois cette seule explication enfin ou
baba serait d'ailleurs le squelette de
volkan ya enfin ça reste une théorie le
monstre du temple du feu ce dernier est
un mangeur de gorron mais a pu être
utilisée dans la tour du jugement
justement pour exécuter des ennemis dit
rude ici reposent l'histoire sanglante
d'hyrule plein de cupidité et de haine
le temple de l'ombre n'était en fait
qu'un préquelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand je parle de zelda j'évite toujours
de trop parler de la timeline de
l'adulte car on t'a moi je n'ai jamais
fait wind waker et c'est probablement
l'un des zelda que je maîtrise le moins
mais nous allons y remédier aujourd'hui
avec une autre théorie personnelle que
je vous ai imaginé tout d'abord
j'aimerais qu'on mettre les choses au
clair car cette théorie est plus folle
que les deux premières
j'aimerais donc déjà que l'on exclut
breath of the wild qu'il serait supposé
être la fin de n'importe quel timeline
enfin on ne sait pas vraiment nintendo
ne souhaite pas réellement l'intégrer à
la timeline donc nous allons les cartes
et et nous en reparlerons dans une
prochaine vidéo car j'ai une surprise à
vous annoncer à la fin
bref revenons aux sujets dans la
timeline de l'adulte nous sommes dans la
partie où le présent a continué de
perdurer bien que l'iq soit remonté dans
le ton grâce à zelda et à l'ocarina du
temps et donc dans cette partie link
n'est plus et donc plus de héros pour
défendre hyrule d'une nouvelle menace
ganondorf euros vient mettre un sacré
bazar les déesses prennent alors la
décision de noyer hyrule pour entre
guillemets reset le monde et nous
arrivons à wind waker sauf que suite à
ses terres son héros gallons d'eau
revient encore une fois mais sera
finalement défait au final par un
nouveau héros
nous arrivons donc à phantom hourglass
suite directe de wind waker
mais tout comme la théorie précédente
avec majora's mask ce zelda n'affectait
en rien la théorie car il se passe dans
une autre dimension
enfin donc nous arrivons à spirit tracks
tetra et link suiteà wind waker et
phantom hourglass ont décidé de voyager
à travers les mers pour trouver de
nouvelles terres
c'est donc le cas avec spirit tracks où
ils formeront le communément appelée
nouvelle héroïne cette terre était déjà
bien habité avant leur arrivée avec le
peuple d'esquimaux oraux ou encore les
locaux mots par exemple et ses nouvelles
terres semblait déjà être pris d'un
certain mal bien avant l'arrivée nos
héros bon on va arrêter tourner autour
du pot pour moi théoriquement mallard
serait la dernière réincarnation de
l'avatar du néant connu dans cette
branche
tout d'abord ganondorf a été tué dans
wind waker et noyer avec tout le reste
du royaume d'hyrule il est vrai que cela
fait débat mais ganondorf n'a plus de
raison d'exister
actuellement néanmoins la malédiction
lancée par l'avatar du néant est
toujours d'actualité et le restera à
jamais donc le monde sera toujours sous
la menace constante d'un potentiel
retour du mal ensuite attaquons nous aux
similitudes entre mme allard et
ganondorf inutile de faire un dessin
concernant la forme de cochon entre les
deux antagonistes
ces deux derniers se font également
appelé roi démon le combat final de
spirit tracks ressemble énormément à
celui de tp mallard prend tout d'abord
le contrôle de zelda comme le fit
ganondorf dans une autre timeline il
faut lui renvoyer également des
projectiles et le battre avec des
flèches et ou arc de lumière similitudes
qu'on ne retrouve pas face à bel om-va
ati ou encore le masque de majora par
exemple pour continuer un détail
éclaircies encore plus cette question
c'est qu'un nouvel élu est né à l'aube
du retour du mal à l'exception de vaty
qui perturbe cet argument les héros et
lui des déesses naissent quand le mâle
réapparaît dû à la malédiction de la
bâtarde une est un argument qui pourrait
potentiellement accentuer cette théorie
phantom hourglass ou encore majora's
mask sont des continuités intégrant le
même link que l'histoire qui les
précèdent
bref il faut également mentionner la
question du temps spirit tracks se situe
un siècle après wind waker un nouveau
hyrule des bâtis nouvelle civilisation
digue
un monde totalement différent du virus
d'origine légué rues d'auch sont une
fois de plus absents et ont disparu
si maladie c'est une réincarnation de
l'avatar il a dû s'habituer à ce nouvel
environnement ce nouveau monde a dû
évoluer d'où le fait qu'il n'est pas un
gay rue de rage ces points si vous me
suivez
néanmoins le problème du temps et du
manque de bagram perturbe un petit peu
la théorie car oui le laps de temps
entre les trois jeu est court et
apparemment malade us est déjà apparue
il ya longtemps
alors est-ce que l'avatar du néant peut
créer plusieurs réincarnation je ne
pense pas vraiment de plus les paies de
légende est resté sur la tête de
ganondorf dans wind waker
mais l'épée des locaux mot pourrait bien
la remplacer s'ils sont des élus des ds
le monde a évolué et a changé tout peut
largement nous laisser croire que mme
allard est une réincarnation de l'avatar
peu d'arguments le contre et j'aime
beaucoup cette idée bien que cela casse
énormément les codes de la franchise
mais n'oubliez pas que le hyrule de
spirit tracks n'est pas le même que
celui des autres zelda
cette branche de la timeline a dû
évoluer et a donc changé
passons maintenant à la fée scam je suis
un réel fans de la saga zelda et je suis
vraiment à fond dessus je suis fier de
vous l'annoncer après énormément de
demandes
une série de cinq vidéos va arriver sur
la chaîne où vous expliquant la timeline
zelda officiel j'aime beaucoup à
raconter des histoires sur youtube et
celle de zelda me passionne énormément
et puis vous me l'avez énormément
demandé il ya déjà maintenant plus d'un
an j'ai réellement envie de voir ce que
ça peut donner
et de voir vos retours ça va être
quelque chose d'assez inédit sur la
chaîne après tout je suis vraiment
impressionné de l'or dans la pop culture
et si ça vous plaît du coup pourquoi pas
continuer bref j'espère en tout cas que
la vidéo vous aura plu donc n'hésitez
pas
et c'est un petit pouce bleus c'est très
important pour moi à laisser un petit
commentaire à vous abonner à me suivre
sur twitter vous pouvez également me
soutenir en regardant quelques pubs sur
du type et j'aimerais remercier à une
recette de sa participation dans la
vidéo il a d'ailleurs fait une vidéo sur
majora's mask qui est vraiment je vous
conseille vraiment d'aller la voir
et puis il va sortir d'autres théories
sur zelda aller c'était argot rock et
que le 'lion' earth soit avec vous
[Musique]